alors ça devrait fonctionner je pense
que ça fonctionne ah ouais je vais
récupérer l'échiquier on va faire ça
maintenant et puis on va pouvoir suivre
le match
ap ap ap
après chic hierla
et donc ils ont doit le mettre en paix
rhdp la tendance va changer la couleur
aussi
on va récupérer les caméras regarder le
match tac tac tac 1
alors ça pète conway où normalement on
verra où elle songé pas changé les noms
parce que tu sais pas c'est la finale
non non c'est c'est le quart de finale
hop c'est parti je vais récupérer les
cas mais elles ont commencé en avance du
coup je vais récupérer les caméras et
puis du coup on va suivre ça hein
reuss a appelé caméra je vais les mettre
attendez ans j'avais un truc ici
malheureusement en attendez attendez je
m'étais mis le truc de côté hop
je récupère le truc
un truc bizarre c'est que j'ai que j'ai
qu'une caméra
un temps déjà un truc bizarre avec les
caméras de petites secondes c'est le
temps de le récupérer ce que j'avais
désolé ans et ouais désolé il ya un
petit jeu sans savoir les deux j'en ai
qu une sur deux ce qui est un peu
dérangeant
attendait
as très étrange vraiment je vais vous
mettre je vais vous mettre
éventuellement la caméra mais en fait le
truc c'est quand je les cadres il faut
mieux que j'ai les deux parce que sinon
en fait c'est je vais je vais donc une
fois que j'en aurai munch aurait obligé
de remettre la deuxième attendez c'est
un bug en fait ça à 19 heures vlad doit
normalement après ok j'ai trouvé comment
faire ça va s'écouler à plus ou moins
le programme il est pas pratique hein je
vous jure leur truc et pas pratique
leur truc est vraiment aucun voilà ça y
est j'ai enfin un vrai c'est bon c'est
bon je pouvoir le faire
c'est disons que si j'avais pas fait ça
on aurait on n'aurait pas eu des trucs
comme il fallait ça et j'ai enfin trouvé
regardez tranquille
ok alors on va capturer
on va capturer les deux jeux juste
attendre points clés non parce que je
sais pas comme ceux qui mettent les
scores je sais pas dans quel côté met
les scores donc ça déjà au moins s'est
fait comme ça c'est une joueuse et moi
on va récupérer la 2e et et on va
attendre après pour savoir si ça permute
ou pas
à permuter on va trouver la deuxième
année de ça on va regarder
à temps et pour les non parce que ça se
peut que ce soit l'eau de l'une ou
l'autre en bas et donc voilà n'hésitez
pas pour détection des questions à
droite on en profite et un de ces
matches pour faire un peu des questions
réponses avec le chat tranquille ou si
vous avez des questions quoi alésien
l'acea s'élevant à tient sa paire une
caisse en un pas de chance aya problèmes
de connexion obs ma tendance à rater ce
n'était pas vu par les blancs le petit
matin qui tombe qui font plaisir ça ça
c'est les petites tactiques qui font
plaisir à paris non mais j'ai fait
exprès voilà on allait on est du bon
côté en fait je fais exprès de permettre
les noms au petit matin un classique un
matin de mai redoutable ah ouais le mat
de la diagonale
c'est toujours c'est toujours fort et ce
qu'elle a écrit elle donc
ah bah oui le mat en un c'est toujours
toujours aussi puissant
c'est la fin de grille sous presse
bien ça c'est penser comme interview
chez rtl arch à tout et tu veux dire
sûrement s était pas mal c'était pas mal
à la kalach sur caen est ton livre
écoute fois je pense qu'à partir de 10
11 ans est possible de lire mes pronos
pour l'euro écoute j'ai pas trop trop
regarder geab son kit ali assez fortes
perturbations du côté de leur side
je suis assez d'accord avec toi ray je
suis assez d'accord avec toi c'est des
joueuses promis à la demande mondiale
situ par un camion par rapport aux 1
mais je crois qu aux alentours de
laquelle était aux alentours c'est cela
la numéro un mondiale actuelle après
l'arrêté les échecs professionnels les
manants prof d'université mais elle doit
encore être aux alentours de la 100e
place mondiale
je pense que je dis vous maîtrisez les
ouvertures de john watson écoute maçons
du coeur gros qu'un recommandé à
beaucoup de gens fois qu'il aime bien
après moi je n'ai jamais eu
tu peux nous expliquer le format alors
c'est 75 minutes de 5 + 1 45 minutes de
3 + 1 et et 25 minutes 2 1 + 1 à la fin
à son prime willy fans je pense qu'elle
est étape 80 même 70e mondiale
katia c'est le diminutif de caterina du
coup c'est plus court et ça rentre mieux
dans le dans la case
être à cacher mon livre le dernier merci
à toi et nana est quelle nationalité
les gens reviennent comme son lundi
qu'en fait les filles non qui sans idées
sont souvent des noms géorgien way we
les fans elle s'était fricot est épris
29 à un en contre nakao speech s
c'était terrible c'était
rible mais pas j'ai ma nana a reserré
que j'ai pas mis gm d'habitude mais j'ai
annuler parce que je les laissais
au-dessus mesure on va le mettre
on va le mettre du conseil quoiqu'en
verture à 1100 à
roger déjà fait des vidéos là dessus et
tu peux jouer à peu près tout un tu peux
jouer à peu près tous les deux sont
grands maîtres je crois que de son grand
maître j'espère pas avoir fait de
bêtises mais de mémoire et de son grand
maître katia je suis sûr à 100% mais a
glissé aussi
car je passais d'autres questions
n'hésitez pas à les y en soit c'est le
best moment c'est le meilleur moment
pour pour le faire ouais c'était 29 à 21
29 arrêts pas c'est assez terrible je
crois que c'était sale corps ou steve 27
à 1 je crois qu'à un moment donné il a
gagné genre 14 ou 15 parties d'affilée
après il en a eu un peu marre
le prochain temps de bakouba écoute y
joue en top 12 bat qui il joue en top 12
bat qui après à la coupe du monde
des pronos pour ce match retouche pas
trop où on va voir un et d'aider
participer à ce tournoi elle a voulu y
participant elle a voulu à la jouer les
qualifs elle apparaît ici
katia le stream non non elle stream pas
après en fait j'ai une deuxième caméra
pour voir leurs écrans c'est un peu le
set-up habitués allant sur internet pour
pour le fair play mais évidemment tu
peux rien savoir après la vue vu les
partis on se doute bien qu'il ya pas d
d'extérieur mai
mais sinon c'est un peu le set-up
habitué à l'internet ou au final n'a pas
vraiment d'arbitrage quoi réception
facile d'analyser une partie en garde
plutôt conjointe parce que t'as pas à
calculer les petites tactiques quand tu
regardes plus facile
qu'est ce qui me pousse à aimer les
échecs roche c'est pas moi j'aime bien
après comme je disais ça ça dépend il ya
des périodes j'aime bien regarder des
tournois d'autres j'aime bien jouer en
fait mais pourquoi faut il céder garde
un équilibre entre les deux quand tu
expliques un joueur comme acquis soient
pas invités plus souvent de gros
tournois vu le niveau qu'il a pu
afficher au grand duché soit oui mais si
tu le fais jouer 10 fois grandes
chaussures comme ça neuf fois sur dix il
finira dernier ou avant dernier en fait
là ça a bien tourné pour baky ça vient
tourner mais en fait si rejoue le
tournoi 10 fois il va finir huit ou neuf
fois dernier ou avant dernier là c'était
le tour nous ça s'est bien passé quoi
qui peut entendre ça il le sait un c
voilà ça s'est bien passé là s'arrête
que des joueurs sont un d'étudiants sur
internet éclatant réel non les blancs
sont beaucoup mieux la non non je pense
pas je pense que les noirs sont mieux
ici j'arrive pas à bien voir le chrono
en fait le chronomètre en fait j'y
arrive pas et j'ai l'impression qu'on
n'a pas le chronomètre
je m'en occuper de ça oui ok j'ai
compris
on va aller on va régler ça
j'arrive pas à l'arrivée c'était ce truc
dallaire totalement on va le virer aussi
çà çà çà cacher les joueuses vouloir
régler ça ah attendez un peu que l'essai
de glisse ça
pourquoi j'y arrive pas en fait ok c'est
bon j'ai réussi
j'arrive ici
du coup la partie se joue là je crois
que les blancs sont nouveaux gagnants en
fait je crois qu'ils n'auront fait
n'importe quoi
ouais parce que il va y avoir du
cavalier cette tour prend des six
je crois que c'est nouveau gagnant pour
les blancs terrible terrible ça va faire
2 0 1
tranquille tranquille katia qui réussit
son début de match
c'est la finale non c'est un quart de
finale
il y aura deux autres quarts de finale
coup sur coup demain de 13h à 19h hacker
français quatre tranches et 4 écart a
lieu trois retours est ce que ça suffit
peut-être pas gecas ap
l'air d'être le coup l'année mais rennes
nancy à des pions pro f 5 échecs qui
traîne mais c'était bien joué j'ai 4
juste à la rate et fou prendre 3 et
supra f5 donc ça perd deux pions mais
dans l'esprit c'était pas mal juste à
perdre et deux pions mais bon ça arrive
hein ça arrive
elle a dû rater quelque chose de
beaucoup plus fort dommage c'est dommage
alors est-ce que la partie peut encore
retourner sûr que l'appareil ferait non
juste à la mal calculé la safer une
pièce non fou g63 trois tours des huit
as et pas été vu quoi que ça permet une
pièce ok c'est sûr juste à la mal
calculé gk chance et qu'elle n'avait
rien vu mais en fait il y avait l'idée
intéressante de d2 je vous la découverte
us salah el amal à elle a mal calculé
bon ok là que deux pions de moins le
pion g et menaçant mais ça peut encore
tourner un cette partie ouest
ça peut même peut-être gagner autant
avec un peu de bol ça peut gagner pour
les blancs ouais non les choses avec les
noirs se fout trop mal autant attention
à ne pas filer un truc en ont quand même
ouais tu aurais fuite
ouais c'est chaud ça joue trop lentement
allez assez chaude de nay
va prendre 17 ça va la récupérer
quelques pions katia ça va le faire
ouais katia elle va réussir à retourner
la finale avec deux pions de moins
maintenant elle a un pion de plus bien
joué un temps sion de pas se faire
clouer elle va ramener le roi à l'efo
jour un peu plus vite qu'est ce qu'elle
fait à les coiffer par 3 je sais pas
allez faut se dépêcher un petit peu là
quand même côté katia prend là bas c'est
sa manière d'être
n'importe quoi des deux côtés là c'est
terrible c'est pas pourquoi le ramène
pas son roi vert vers les pions c'est un
mystère alors dû faire ça est déjà très
longtemps
ça va jouer le roi qui va partir en a
trois qui va attaquer le fou aller 1-1
la magnifique tête elle peut la faire
tomber à les rebelles à tours angers ce
à quoi elle va gagner 11 0 elle a joué
avec 1,02
oui à la gagne autant me oui cette fin
de partie magnifique les amis j'ai rien
compris j'ai compris air mais elle a
fait tomber bien joué ça devient jouer
bonne fin de partie
un vitrier fans disent harbaoui fanel
rebelles joue plus vraiment donc non pas
là on n'avait rien compris à la finale
on n'a pas trop compris ce que ça
faisait non en vrai je serai plus à
ripper devoir katia contre ou contre des
joueurs du haut niveau en fait ce que je
suis un peu le top 12 ans pas du tout à
moins qu'ils aient maxime qui joue une
partie contre quelqu'un de fort mais le
top 12 à proprement dire non j'ai déjà
parlé avant pour moi les interclubs aux
échecs ça ça fait pas trop de sens en
fait parce que c'est un sport individuel
donc je disais tout à l'heure qu'on sait
en nation c'est marrant à très petite
dose mais mais mais mais mais pas mais
pas comme ça
c'est pas un niveau bac à bac y ait
beaucoup beaucoup plus fort hein il ya
des français que je sais ce pitch est ce
nom là ça a l'air d'être cool pour katia
une nouvelle fois avec les noirs un
katia là oui on va on va essayer de
tourner l'échiquier à chaque fois pour
être du bon côté avec la cam en fait
même partie que la première mais pas
pris ce pas je pense qu'elle va pas
prendre ce prendre des maths en 1 à
toutes les parties mais bon ça peut vite
faire un gros score en fait ce match ce
que katia est globalement plus forte et
away
voilà classement me fallait pas mélanger
deux journées un peu par par les uns sur
dans l'interview j'ai fait sur russia
today
moi je ferai pour hank soient mélangées
et enfoncerait hyper hype et d'avoir des
défis qui arrive à haut niveau
la difficulté sur des échecs
lorsque lorsque tu as des compétitions
féminines
en fait contrairement aux autres sports
c'est qu'en fait le contenu qui a sur
l'échiquier exactement pareil disons
quand tu regardes un sport pas rentrer
du tennis en fait juste les femmes
physiquement tap - fort donc donc le jeu
si tu veux est différent là le truc au
pas parce que voilà il ya les hommes
physiquement sont plus plus plus
costauds quoi donc ita plus fort et
c'est un jeu un peu différent la
difficulté avec les échecs c'est
exactement le même jeu sauf que ça joue
moins bien en fait
et ça c'est un peu la difficulté est
alors qu'intrinsèquement les femmes
peuvent tout aussi bien que les hommes
en réalité il ya l'exemple de de judit
polgar qui avait réussi à rivaliser avec
les hommes donc ya pas de raisons pour
lesquelles les femmes doivent moins bien
joué que les hameaux échec si ce n'est
un problème statistiques ce qui a plus
d'homme qui jouent et est donc en soi
c'est un peu dommage entre guillemets
pas voir les filles qui jouent avec les
hommes quoi c'est un petit peu dommage
là les bleus ont réussi à obtenir un
petit quelque chose on va voir un par 4
apprennent vite le large mais là cette
partie est plutôt bien gérée par nana à
voir
il aurait menacé un match en mains pour
katia sait combien le classement elo je
pense qu'elle pourrait redevenir numéro
un mondial femme très rapidement si elle
voulait à judith après maman elle fait
d'autres choses dans sa vie et c'est
plus forcément son objectif 1
fait que les âmes des femmes de joucas
entre elles contribuent à cette
différence de niveau pour moi où il ya
un pour moi oui mon ma conviction
personnelle c'est que oui après c'est
qu'il n'ya pas d'étude qui le prouve un
mea mais ma conviction c'est que le fait
de faire jouer les femmes
systématiquement entre elles comme il ya
moins de compétition et que c'est plus
facile sacré - d'émulation et donc ça
fait baisser leur niveau intrinsèque
mais comme je vous dis ça repose pas sur
des études ou quoi que ce soit ça c'est
une conviction personnelle quand je suis
au niveau par rapport à l'ol sont
beaucoup plus fortes que moi en longues
et en rapide après en blitz sur internet
tout est un peu plus fort ça dépend des
formats dans ce format là je suis ce
format là pardon je suis censé être un
peu plus fort je pense avoir gardé lui
et lomax de katia tu vois on se faire un
avis je parlais juste on va perdre une
petite seconde
fall a moins joué que moi murray sont
ils au max et 27 81 et away ont pas plus
forte que toutes mais certaines
je pense à apprendre en f3 et changer
les dames tour ses six tours prend 1,7
tout reprend des 6es turbo d'euros
[ __ ] un bon résultat avec les noirs 1
dans un match comme ça tu mène déjà 2-0
turf nuls avec les noirs
dans le niveau scolaire ouais mais
l'école c'est pas une compétition c'est
différent là on parle d'un sport de
compétition c'est pas comme l'école un
des possibles se croiser un jour dans un
parc
c'était à paris non je suis pas du tout
un pari frérot
est ce que kaka va essayer de gagner ça
elle peut un peu tentés tête elle peut
faire tour des cadres des jarrets à lui
a laissé tout reprend h4 c'est déjà
avantage noir ouais c'est fou d'avoir
laissé ça fallait faire rager 2,3 g iii
pour empêcher la tourbe et quatre
enfants hkd c'est petit avantage quand
même ça va être complètement nul mais à
ce niveau là ça peut se tenter à ce
niveau là ça peut se jouer
ouais ça peut se gagner ça hein ce
niveau ça peut se jouer
ça peut se gagner avec le temps après
c'est nul mais mais bon j'ai 5 f 6 3 et
6 3 f 5 h 4 au f4 bon c'est rien mais
bon ça se joue un
ça stand de ou fin
mais la tour en a quatre pions hk 3 f53
f4 mais normalement il va faire tours à
huit à sept à huit est là elle troquera
le pion métal tendre est l'option
jusqu'en f5
tu peux peut-être essayer d'avoir un
deux contre un il gagner comme je vous
dise à ce niveau là ça peut peut-être se
gagner ouais surtout que là ouais nan le
set-up défensive des blancs là est loin
d'être super parce qu'après hk de toute
façon elle va t'en ou faisant donc elle
a perdu des tempos ouais ça sent qu'elle
sait pas comment faire avec les blancs
ce qui peut donner envie de faire h 4 à
8 3 f 4 à 6 f 5 à 7 et heureusement elle
encore au tempo il y aura pas tourcoing
3 y aura tour bouge
heureusement pascal a perdu 2,3 temps
pour rien annonce utiliser à ce niveau
là ça peut se jouer pour gagner
le niveau haut niveau au niveau au top
niveau du retour à 4 et turbo d'euros la
même ça ça se joue un peu ce qui est
cool hein ça fait plaisir dans la sphère
à 6 absolument c'est el feitouri fitch
f5 qu'est ce que ça peut commencer à
devenir dangereux attend là y'a
peut-être h3 maintenant puisque roy
prend roi prend peut-être h trois échecs
ce temps d'ici je tenterai rouages trois
essais tentés attendant elle peut la
gagner
et maintenant roi prend f3a ouais mais
c'est déjà perdant trois premières 3 ça
gagne parce qu'il va y avoir trois
points f2 and lights tour à quatre là
aussi elle voit tour à 4 c'est fini
ces trois points f2 surtout aurait fui
trois problèmes de tours pour assister à
ces tours à quatre tours à je suis de
forcer tout reprend et finito hockey
mais tour à 4 c'est pas le coup de plus
durant les sert à table raté rappel
dommage dommage dommage ça rate et le
gain elle aurait pu la gagner
ouais mais tour à 4o hd y avait trois
points f2 et ça continue à menacer maths
ça aurait gagné bon maintenant elle peut
encore la gagne et salin vous savez ici
tout est possible mais malheureusement
ref 3 effet tour à 5 ces rois g6
je pense qu'à faire un coup comme tour
ici un change contant je tenterai tour à
deux pour tours f8 am et tour à 6 tours
f6 et c'est dommage
elle aurait pu la gagner sakic au hasard
ouais ouais là c'est touré fuite c'est
une stand d'euros c'est dommage j'ai eu
du bon kick au hasard
allez c'est peut-être ça en fait
l'intérêt de cette compét
c'est vrai que là on a dû cliquer au
hasard de partout ouais ok ça a cliqué
au hasard ce s'écoule
bon allez c'est ce que ça va continuer à
cliquer au hasard
ça va continuer à cliquer au hasard si
on rentre dans une petite flèche nikov
ça fait plaisir le clic au hasard
ça fait très plaisir je pense qu'encore
plus de hazard prend la casse des cinq
ça roulait même position à voir ces jeux
petite flèche nikov les filles changent
moins d'ouvertures que les garçons il ya
un truc assez bizarre qui se passe aussi
dans les différences comme vous ment
pareils et c'est que les filles souvent
même quand elles ont les blancs
même si l'ouverture c'est malpasset la
rejoue en fait si un truc assez étrange
mais elle elle rejoue souvent la même
ouverture la même position mais même
s'ils allaient même si ça se passe pas
bien
alors que les garçons le plus souvent
ils changent quand ça se passe mal dans
l'ouverture
il essaye de varier les filles elles
restent quand même sur le truc qu'elle
avait prévu de base généralement si elle
avait un plan de jeu qu'elle avait prévu
une ouverture même ça se passe pas très
bien elle elle reste dedans
wes gannon lascif un match comme un
speech est c'est que ça se passe mal
quelque part il va changer de variantes
un mail et fit souvent elles brest dans
leur truc quoi après c'est du ces il ya
du positif et du négatif là dans le
négatif sebaâ cité moins bien tu vas
rester moins bien après l' avantage
c'est que tu sais ce que tu as quoi
tu sais ce que tu as tu change pas tu
des fois nous quand on change on empire
moi c'est vrai ça se passe mal sur une
ouverture en fait je vais changer mais
mais je vais peut-être me retrouve avec
pire puis encore pire tu encore pire les
filles elle en fait elles vont rejouer
cinq six sept huit fois un truc un peu
inférieur avec les blancs et continuer
quoi mais ça c'est vrai c'est se dire
dans ces matches là en tout cas c'est
une différence qu'on a pu remarquer
d'ailleurs là on voit que c'est toujours
les mêmes ouverture est normalement
elles vont continuer là-dessus vraiment
jusque jusqu'au bout de la nuit
ben kattra dans son match contre goody
n'a par exemple là elle avait joué des
carreaux cannes avec les blancs qui sont
toujours mal passé je crois qu'elle a
rejoué la même peut-être six ou sept
fois s'est mal passé si cette fois
d'affilée mais mais elle a continué à la
jouer bon alors après à certaines
parties qu'elles aient gagné quand même
genre là elle était moins bien tout à
l'heure et encore moins bien avec les
blancs mais c'est sûr qu elle rejouera
le même truc quand même à mon avis c'est
une différence d'attitude en fait
changez 6e 4 ça se passe mal vous voyez
des reins souvent quand je joue des
longs matches 2005 des gens 6e 4 ça se
passe mal je vais sur des cats 6 e 4 des
d4 ça se passe mal je suis un peu dans
la merde
mais même si je connais pas trop je vais
quand même changé si tout se passe mal
je vais quand même changé me dire tiens
ma tête je vais ouvrir un truc qui se
passe bien et puis au moins ça ça lui
posera un problème à lui
ouais ce défi à moins ce truc là après
quand elles ont des coachs et que et qui
a des seconds ans autour étoiles change
évidemment mais par elles mêmes elles
changent moins
donc là je me demande si elle va changer
la troisième partie katyal logiquement
elle devrai mais pas très sûr du là je
crois si tout se passe mal avec les
blancs ouais c'est possible en fait on
est juste à 3 au premier coup j'en sais
rien mais oui ça se passe vraiment très
mal et tu vois ça me saoule leur évite
d'être aides avec les blancs déjà pour
la deuxième partie d'affilée
enfin changent quelque part je sais pas
où mais changent quelque part après
katja là elle joue plus vite quand même
à petit on prend quatre ça doit pas être
un bon parce qu'elle peut pas faire des
cinq après fou 4
normalement il faudrait qu'elle fasse
des cinq donc est pas bête
j'avais pas vu tour f 4k valider cinq
jouer
qu'à valider
vraiment bien joué qui a aidé 5 de katia
elle a bloqué après le problème c'est
son droit quand même là jamais gros rock
et ou 4 ouais non ça c'est bien joué le
4 aussi bonne impression qui est noir
comme une position plus agréable il ya
beaucoup de cases et le roi blanc est un
peu bizarre peuvent avoir joué tour d
une façon qu'en europe qu'on n'aura pas
essayer de fixer loi le fou c4 bien joué
aussi
il n'y a aucun
misogyne et c'est ce colloque aux locaux
absolument pas misogyne enfin c'est
terrible de dire ça c'est juste c'est
juste des constatations sur des
différences qui sont qui existe en
france et pas trop trop pourquoi et
comme je disais ça peut être des ça peut
être bon comme mauvais parce que katia
l'a finalement elle rejoue ça n'allait
pas très bien me l'a peut-être là elle
va peut-être la gagne et quand même
c'est pour expliquer les différences
entre les attitudes des joueurs des
joueuses comme c'est souvent demandé mes
cd des attitudes qui sont différentes
face aux ouvertures face aux
préparations et c'est un fait quoi c'est
juste un fait je crois je serai
micheline de dire ça en fait d'expliquer
la différence dans le jeu
c'est je sais pas c'est bizarre mais
avec pour les jam est émis sont
différentes entre les hommes et les
femmes bas en fait il ya les deux balles
apparemment ça elles sont toutes les
deux grands maîtres mixte
enfin c'est également cette et misogynes
de dire ça en fait alors que j'essaie
d'expliquer pour la pour la peine un
truc intéressant dans dans la différence
d'à proche du jeu eux et dans les
attitudes quoi et pour la peine il faut
que c'était intéressant fin
et du coup au contraire et puis en plus
je prenais l'exemple du match de katia
contre contre goody nage suis pas sûr
que la personne est regardée
contrairement à moi qui suis au courant
forcément bon nous on faire et ce que je
disais des fois ça marche bien des fois
ça marche pas bien des fois on se
retrouve en plein tilt à changer tout le
temps et ça se passe mal on l'a katia va
encore gagner un comme quoi parce que
gisèle ouverture se passe mal mais elle
gagne à chaque fois donc fait à la tête
raison juste ne va pas le faire par
principe ouest du coup moi je pense que
je rentrerai dans la [ __ ] couleurs
opposées même si elle gagne pas mais a
fait bon être un peu con ça m'a embêté
tour ces deux en fait
ouais
par contre ce que disait pas le gars ben
moi je trouve que c'est surtout le fait
d'avoir des compétitions mixtes féminine
qui pénalise les filles qui pour arriver
à un haut niveau
je sais que pas le garant en anjou et
par elle quand elle était quand elle
était enfant son père a été strictement
contre en fait donc elle a très vite
participer uniquement à des compétitions
à des compétitions mixtes et je pense
que c'était un bien pour elle
non mais c'est fou de pas pouvoir parler
librement de ses sujets en essayant
d'apporter des points de vue constructif
et intéressant pour la peine et non
perdu là c'est tout ce qu'on faisait ça
à faire mieux là auraient dû rentrer
dans la foule heures ont pesé tout à
l'heure mais elle devait être nulle aux
siens après elle peut gagner autant son
adversaire a pas l'air d'être très
rapides katia juste il faut être un peu
marre loup
ouais voilà sûrement raté son va tout
dans une finale plus compliqué alors eu
de meilleures chances là le problème
c'est que c'est vraiment très simple de
faire nul
maintenant elle va puis arrive et katia
je pense qu'elle va réfléchir à quatre
pour faire tomber mais as well as il a
eu un petit manque de lucidité je pense
gloria le truc aussi c'est qu'une femme
si elle arrive à 2500 et l'ol va elle va
pouvoir vivre des échecs ou une petite
pause sais pas trop pourquoi alors qu'un
homme il faut qu'ils arrivent au moins
2700 pour être vraiment sérieux sérieux
quoi du coup il ya aussi le fait que tu
arrêtes a moins besoin d'eux
de travailler pour y arriver quoi et du
coup ça a créé des objectifs - dre et du
coup bah c'est pas c'est parce qu'il
faut pour faire du sport de haut niveau
malheureusement
objectif moindre forcément ça t'amène -
ou quoi c'est assez c'est une vérité 1
c1 contre je pense qu'elles ont su
qu'elle ferait une pause
sam hill chronomètre sur 0 je sais pas
pourquoi je suis pas prêt une position
les amis va vous dire
non
à voir je sais pas croyez une pause en
fait donc je peux pas vous dire je ne
connais pas la raison de cette pause qui
n'était pas prévu et on peut dire que
pose il ya
jacques aucune idée d'eux pourquoi
peut-être pause fraîcheur ouais je sais
pas à la rigueur on s'en fout aussi
avait envie de dire j'ai envie de dire
on s'en fout un peu aussi de savoir
pourquoi pause il ya bon ben voilà il ya
posé à pezens
ouais je sais pas je suis un peu étonné
de cette pause mais bon faire ma foi
tant mieux enfin tant mieux petite pause
est que la qui part
[Musique]
et échouent chez moi aujourd'hui
n'empêche vous avez une limonade qu'il
faut c'est foutu cette allée la chercher
moi aussi un tout fait une pause 1
pourquoi pas un faire de la belle pose
je regarde même c'est pas moi qui ai un
prêt non non non il n'y a plus de parti
un elles sont en train de débattre dans
le chatt switch non moi je me prendre la
limonade un ballack a au bout d'un
moment je ne vois pas la fin il n'y a
rien d'écrit en fait c'était un petit 10
écrits par un écrit juste elles sont
parties comme ça d'un seul coup mais
katia qui avec une bouteille d'eau mais
je prends de la limonade un maintien en
fait aller facilement ouvrir la fenêtre
on va se mettre bien
je ne sais pas pourquoi il ya c'est très
étonnant étonnant puisqu'on et on n'est
pas prêt non plus un moment de match
en vrai le tapis au mondial est
tellement compliquées qu'elles ont aucun
intérêt à jouer elles peuvent très bien
avec des trains comme celui-ci bah je
sais pas un frère off c'est une question
complexe à ce truc tu vas dès qu'on
essaie d'en parler sérieusement tu as
des gens qui sont pas contents donc on
ça va reprendre
on peut dire que ça se passait plutôt
bien pour capter avec les noirs donc on
va voir si ça continue
on va voir à la sarre joue pas pour le
moment
marrant cette pause quand même très
impromptue ma foi
étrange un très étrange
très très étrange très étrange du coup
hockey est ce que ça change vraiment ça
ça ouais ça change intéressant mais il
ya eu pose à la tient il pose des
sachants d'ouverture est ce que est ce
qu'il ya eu
est ce qu'il ya eu du coaching risque a
eu du coaching ou pas c'est vraiment
parce que ça rebondit un peu sur ce que
je vous disais tout à l'heure que les
filles changent et rarement d'ouverture
elles resteront dans le dans le dans le
même truc et et que souvent c'est les
seconds ans qui donnait des conseils sur
ce genre de choses
et alors là on peut pas savoir la plus
décider par elle même elle a pas eu des
superpositions avec les blancs mais
mais la coïncidence est quand même
intéressante la coïncidence est quand
même intéressante donc là ça file un
pion mais il doit y avoir quelque chose
sur dame prend prisé fou prend soin pas
je vois pas ce qui marche pas mais ouais
c'était juste de l'activité à base de
cavalli c6 et ça joue à l'améliorer non
mais c'est peut-être juste on peut
passer en tête qu'elle a eu le temps de
réfléchir aux siens de pendant la pause
c'est la durée car une bonne cinq
minutes cette pause
donc elle a eu le temps éventuellement
de
bah de récupérer de faire le tri dans
ses idées il est aussi possible
simplement qu'elle est qu'elle ait
rencontré qu'à calais quelqu'un chez
elles ou qu'elles aient eu quelqu'un qui
lui ait dit ou qu'ils eurent envoyé un
message change ouverture joue si vous ça
les deux sont possibles un don qu'elle
prend le pion
doit y avoir de l'activité avec les
noirs moi j'aurais pas du tout peur avec
les blancs je vois juste l'impression
d'avoir gagné un pion mais katia fait ça
de manière si rapide
c'est pas con
comme de la triche non non non non la
com com c'est absolument invérifiable il
s il a scotché quand y'a des quand il ya
des pauses parce qu'il n'y a aucun moyen
de vérifier donc là ce serait ce serait
idiot de l'interdire en fait parce que
c'est impossible de demander aux joueurs
d'avoir des caméras dans toutes les
pièces de vérifier qu'ils touchent pas
leur téléphone phare un moment donné tu
sais pas sur quoi sur cavani g4 dans
pire tu peux d'écrouer par cars et les
détroits j'imagine d'ailleurs peut-être
cavaliers detroit est un coup ici pour
éviter qu'ils et b4 carré lisse et 5
bon
ce qui est sûr c'est que zain zain a
fait une grossière erreur c'est
d'utiliser beaucoup trop de temps elle
se met beaucoup trop mal autant donc je
pense qu'elle n'a aucune chance de
gagner ce match en fait
k&b quatre tours c1 et là il va y avoir
du fleuve 5 1 qui peut être gênant
attention à sa menace quasi mat avec une
partie sur chaque mois tu vois ça en
terme de temps est-ce que le temps a
speech est ce rapport de l'aee lougheed
non ce sont des tournois non classées
avis amicaux c'est genre d'exhibition
après il ya quand même un groupe prize
pool ce que je crois qu'il ya soixante
six mille dollars a gagné en tout ce qui
a un prize pool
alors on va pas dire équivalent aux
grandes choses pour paris mais c'est
quand même pas loin
richard est très complexe position est
très complexe
je préférais toujours les blancs mais
bon truc c'est que c'est pas facile
envie de ça à gérer c'est peut-être même
pas vraiment mieux pour les blancs 1
là on peut peut-être faire qu'il prend
1,5 intermédiaires et cliquez sur fou
prend 1,8 d'avoir cavaliers detroit
c'était une option
j'ai pas pourquoi elle hésite à faire
qui les prend 1,5 qui on prend france
paraît assez logique parce que sa menace
détroit puis on prend france et 3 double
échec à fait fou h6 peut-être pas mal
mais mon tour d un fou ces deux tours 17
dutourd pont des cinq maintenant il y
aura des découvertes fois ça a l'air
d'être assez mal joué ce fois ci c'était
bizarre ouais ça se voit sur la caméra
elle a raté quelque chose
ouais wash 3
ok elle veut qu'elles réalisent ces deux
époux trois matches ça c'est joli ça et
l'autre ne manque et elle peut ne pas le
voir nana na na ne peut ne pas le voir
qualifié de fou trois matches elle a
raté deux matches en un tout à l'heure
là c'est un match qui est pas forcément
simple à voir je pense qu'elle va faire
cavaler ces deux quand même mais là
katia fait un peu n'importe quoi dans
cette partie et où ils apposent a
peut-être fait tourner le match les amis
f5 ouais non là c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
c'est du grand n'importe quoi lasser
foule trolling que ça laisse car l epr
en cavale et m6 qui avait pris huit
foule trolling très mauvaise partie de
katia ici elle avait peut-être une
position potable mais sa foule troll là
sur oise
il peut avoir des fous des 5 x 3 en plus
qui peuvent être assez joli il est déjà
temps de penser à l'abandon ici hausse à
kiko hasard là ouais
là je ferais bien x 3 sa place quand
même il faut à 3 qui fait toujours du
bien
s'ils jouaient ce que j'aurais dû y ait
fana les plus fortes que moi en blitz
donc non oui fans est clairement plus
forte contre katia j'aurais du mal aussi
fat cats chats kosteniuk il ya quelques
joueuses qui sont qui sont assez
pénibles
là je cours à quoi il fait parfois trois
échecs et qui est prend 1,8 tempo ça
s'invente des life
ouais c'est là dessus en fait que c'est
ce genre de moments qu'il a sa pensée
que na na na aucune chance mais qui est
prêt à deux c'était bizarre quand même
là sans s'amender life ball elle
s'invente une d'iphone de ouf
là elle s'invente une life 2 ouf nana
non mais c'est à rim de claquer une
minute et cas là dessus c'est ouais
c'est exactement ce que j'explique dans
les sacs battle la seule manière de
perdre ce genre de trucs
ces deux filets du temps comme ça en
fait voilà faroy prend 1,8 après ça
gagne fall a de la chance c'est qu'on
l'était en gagnant partout il ya du fou
ces six échecs et c'est complètement
fini mais mais
seule chambre et non elle va gagner
quand même facilement mais la seule
chance de perdre parfois c'est quand
même de soupe mal autant comme ça
à phu des singles c'est peut-être
bizarre je pense que foix iii était plus
cool
très honnêtement
elle a fait ses six sur fois à 3,5
mais bon il y aura foule prend celle ci
s'étant mais c'est hyper sympa à gagner
elle se met le feu à une nana toute
seule c'est terrible de se mettre aussi
mal autant pour air assez terrible
heureusement quelques elle part avec une
avant cela il ya foule trois matches en
un heureusement pour elle qu'elle a une
avance de ouf
en début de finale parce que ça aurait
pu troll jusqu'à une défaite ça aurait
pu tout ça aurait pu totalement troll
si elle fait cavalier b4 savate roll on
si elle trouve cavale et bekaert on
prend ces saintes qui a et b d3 savate
rôle un mickey au nom elle le trouve pas
oui mais ça pétrole quand même oh ça
troll ça troll oh oui elle fout pro 3
foot pro f 4 c'est terrible ah non non
non c'est elle est un peu juste avec les
noirs quel dommage france est à deux
doigts de gagner un truc avec avec
tournée de deux mois
alejo f6 peut-être lé roi f67 le fou en
sait-on bloc mais sa paire le pion la ba
ouai c'est terrible ça doit être
en perdant pour les noirs
malheureusement peut-être fou détroit il
n'y a pas de menace poussé deux mois
c'est terrible à la récupère les pions
ça troll ça troll côté nana qui prend
des 5 fu et 4
mais oui mais oui mais oui fou prend ses
4 vous prend aussi soin extraordinaire
cette fois de partir c'est magique
mais voilà les échecs que j'aime au
hautbois là je suis content bon là je
suis content une partie comme ça me fait
très plaisir
on l'a on était sur un level de cliquer
au hasard assez exceptionnel c'étaient
les beaux échec qu'on aime ici on est
toujours heureux de ces partis cliquer
au hasard niveau 10 sa clique au hasard
c'était beau ça fait plaisir plaisir du
petit clic au hasard comme ça il faut
s'en délecter on sait même pas si ça va
gagner on a ça a continué à cliquer au
hasard de partout c'est magnifique ça va
gagner le plus rage 3 c'est très
technique et maintenant ça pousse
silence ça pousse et le fou qui va
revenir en 4 et le roi qui va venir en
g2 extraordinaire est parti ça battles
baron food magnifique je vous ai dit
elle elle et sa santé qu'elle était
capable de perdre retour de plus nette
en plus c'est ton de plus ces activités
quoi terrible de perdre ça voilà c'est
terminé on déjà le match à mon avis les
amis quand on est capable de perdre ça
le match est fini
ah non là
est beau quand même là on était sur du
très lourd
ikos code-barres en fou à ben oui à la
seconde incrément ouais mais ok quand tu
as une minute 45 que tu es complètement
gagnant de ta tour de plus en fait je
les dires le seul manier la seule
manière de perdre c'est s'inventer une
life c'était la seule manière de perdre
c'est de faire ce qu'elle a fait en fait
c'est de se [ __ ] ma l'otan et après de
gaffes et c'était la seule manière de
perdre en fait c'était imperdable
c'était impossible de perdre sauf sauf
troll exceptionnel ça fait plaisir
ça fait plus
dir
vous délecter pas de ce genre de moment
les gars c'est ce qu'on veut voir un de
base de base c'est toujours ce qu'on
espère un peu de clics au hasard hein on
est encore en train de se [ __ ] de ma
gueule
non non on a on a trouvé on a trouvé t
équivalent en grand maître baron fou on
cherche des équivalents baron fou et là
je pense qu'on est en train de trouver
du bon poisson honteux glorifie s'arrêta
et tu cries moi c'est pas drôle
ah bah c'est pas notre problème c'est
pas notre guerre c'est pas notre équipe
un bon là c'est leur lie fin à l'essai
battle si c'était pas nous qui jouions
enfin serait pas serait pas marrant quoi
le baron le baron est toujours là mais
quand même pour qu'à terme le bon enfin
c'est pas quand la prochaine cette
battle
il y en aura probablement une le 1er mai
avec un format complètement différent et
après les abattages classiques vont
reprendre dans une dizaine de jours
avec quelle équipe alors on reprendra
alors ce sera les deux chaises bras mais
on va tenter un format différent avec
quatre joueurs seulement à
et un truc par équipe complètement
différent on va rajouter les caméras etc
enfin on va tenter un truc très très
nouveau c'était une de mes idées et les
bras ont accepté à faire le bras gauche
en tout cas accepté de renvoyer un match
test avec un mais
on va tenter ça avec avec les pieds ou
avec les bras enfin avec avec lecce ce
bras et après donc ça va être un petit
format test
il était absent entre le 9 et le 19
juillet est donc là ça bat à l'après
contre ana je crois que c'est dans la
semaine du 5 au 11
on essaiera d'en mettre une on essaiera
d'en mettre une le 14 juillet aussi on a
quatre
bien et elle a changé d'ouverture aussi
comme quoi c'est marrant la pause les
deux joueuses ont changé d'ouverture je
dis ça je dis rien donc
ça a l'air
un peu dégueu pour les blancs 4 c est
tout le temps mal en fait au dire quand
même que katia dé a des gros problèmes
mais elle l arnaque sur dix ans et de
céréales comme tafer écoute
il y en a pas dans cette compétition
dans après je demande à sare de pour le
moment il n'était pas très chaud pour en
faire donc pour le moment
pour le moment non pour le moment non
jab sens qu'elle va perdre l'option à 5
en force en fait katia elle n'a pas fait
une bonne partie la rue les fiches à la
pause mais non je pense qu'il ya eu un
coaching à la pause
du petit coaching
j'ai pas prêt
pas le pion parce qu'elle peut effet
recueilli ces six après page pas
pourquoi les hits ya peut-être un truc
avec ses 5
c'est ça le problème de nanas en fait ce
qu'elle prend trop de temps là ça
devrait passer quand même inversée chez
moi j'aurais dû renverser l'échiquier
pour avoir les les calmes du bon côté tu
as tout à fait raison
il y avait sept défendent pions et qui
arrive à revenir en c5 ouais ça peut
quand même être inquiétant pour katia
puisqu'elle est quand même mal tout le
temps
ouais
m terrible terrible position est
complètement foutu pour les blancs deux
très mauvaises parties de katia vraiment
de la chance si elle s'en tire bien là
même si elle perd c'est là ça fera un
sur deux et c'est vrai que les
changements d'ouverture finalement on en
parlait juste avant de ce truc assez
lent on en parlait en début de match
avant que le gave
c'était de la misogynie dire ça se met
complètement incroyable mais à maywood
finalement elle a changé d'ouverture et
ça s'est moins bien placé passé
et qu'at t a tout à l'heure elle joué
son truc où elle était moins bien qui se
passait pas très bien en l'ouverture
mais où est l'arnaqué systématiquement
comme quoi elle a décidé de changer et
ça se passe vraiment très mal non mais
la politique est vraiment complètement
foutu
il faut qu'elle tend de tourbe et 5
retour à 5 il va y avoir tourné un échec
je pense dame prendre un prend ayyad
ucam v8 dame prend b6 marlou et sur dame
1 il y aura cavaliers ou ici cavaliers
g4 dame v6 qui tous comme ça qui défend
tous ménages a encore du temps à la fin
n'importe quels pouvaient fort tu veux
juste faire rager 7 mai elles
recommencent à faire le trolling de tout
à l'heure
regardez elle est déjà en mode full
troll là ça troll ll est en train de vie
je vais vous dire combien de temps à la
claque et je vais voir combien de temps
elle a dépensé pour ce coup c'est
criminel de dépenser autant de temps sur
un coup aussi facile à ce que tous les
coûts vont en fait un simple roi g7
suffi pour éviter les échecs
elle va claquer quasiment une minute
dans cette position fait retour b2 en
soi c'est un bon coup un mais mais c'est
pas possible
après c'est vraiment un bon coin mais la
claque et combien de temps pour le tour
b 2 elle a craqué 52 secondes quand même
apprécié elle voit cavaliers ou quatre
ici c'est vrai que c'est tellement
termine à dos faux
avec ava lieu 4 c'est pas si simple
voire cavalier e 4 e nassef de dame
prend 1,4 d'un problème de toute façon
c'était simple alors à jouer tempo et si
elle le trouve
mais bon elle a dû claquer 18 secondes
bon là c'est terminé
ce qui n'a pas toujours à 7 en fait
c'est le problème il y aurait tout
racette ça pourrait être chaud
non là y'a plus de coups elle va tenter
tour s'est vite je pense qu' un coup un
peu désespéré damas cette c5 pour
essayer de rester en vie humaine qu'elle
va faire dame des cas d'un problème de
hockey du coup ça ça peut s'attaquer de
nouveau parce que le temps justement
elle s'est foutu tellement mal autant
qui peut lui arriver des carabistouilles
il peut y arriver entoure ces sept fous
aussi sous truc comme ça voilà tour
c'est ça déjà tempo à l'écarter à tour
ses sept plus vite
allez la tour ans et 7 le fond des 5 va
pas la remarque est allé la tour en 17
allée tour 17 mais non il ya roi ici
assez terrible de parfaits tour des sept
fous des cinq plus vite
aïe aïe aïe quel dommage pour x 4 c'est
bien joué par contre un tour à deux là
encore ok il ya encore de la marge ou
tri ont bien joué de la part de dana
alors il as
à part de nana elle a trouvé les bons
coups là à mes attentes
cinq échecs et torah 5 à l'arrêt alors
la champions en 1 et four b3 foot pro f
7 elle se fait de nouveau marlou tait
quel dommage pour nana
quel dommage quel dommage et ouais mais
si tu peux pas gagner ses positions le
match va être compliqué hein je vous le
dis tout de suite si elle réussit pas à
gagner ces trucs là le match va être dur
est obligé de gagner ces trucs là en
fait si tu peux pas gagner final deux ou
trois pions de plus tu peux pas gagner
un match d'échecs quoi c'est pas
possible
terrible mais non c'était répond tu peux
pas gagner ça c'est c'est un énorme
problème en fait tu dois vraiment faire
9 sur 10 ans ce genre de position là les
1/2 sur deux aux ailerons fait une pause
c'est terrible on s'attend le caniveau
pause ouais mais en fait elle est trop
longtemps trop longtemps
ouais ça elle a trop de la trop lent
c'en est dans le tronc de ce qu'elle a
fait
mais c'est vrai mais c'est sa 2006
sanchez comme ça à peu près le niveau
entre guillemets c'est pas péjoratif
mais c'est à peu près le niveau 1
moi je vois quand il faut vraiment que
que je fois exténué pour retomber comme
ça je vois à peu près au niveau que
c'est à peu près ça ouais ça troll
sivola ça peut vraiment rôle est encore
au niveau de katia 2700 ça travaille
déjà un peu moins mais moi je troll
encore à partir de 28 de cinquante 29,8
roll plus
4 nages a détruit pas du tout envie de
ça bien loin de là elle repart pour 3,8
c'est la même partie tout à l'heure
c'est marrant parce qu'elle a perdu à la
touriste
elle repart pour le même truc elle a
fait la pause à la changer elle repart
dans la même connerie quoi c'est
terrible ok là il fallait faire cavalier
prend 1,5
c'est là qu'elle s'était trompée à ces
terribles elle répète la même partie où
elle avait une tour de moins ça je
comprends pas ça je comprends pas ça
c'est du troll banquet qui avait
prononcé il faut prendre 5 ça semble
encore aller si elle refait fois çi ce
jeu rachitique le si elle refait fois ci
ce jeu rage quit le stream ok
cette fois ci je rage quittait montréal
doit être gagnante en fait presque 20
gagnants de j'exagère mais elle a une
belle position ce qu'elles menacent
cavale et prend à deux cavaliers prend
1,2 foot prend b2 tour prend b3 et à la
queue un pion de moins et à l'est les
cavaliers c2 qui qui rôdent dans la lah
patrol katia elle à répéter jusqu au bon
moment cette fois ci
la patronne des trois surtout non je
pense pas fou des trois chansons
cavaliers prend à deux et qui a validé
trois aussi oui puis on prend des trois
fous quand ces trois sages avait dit
dans la partie précédente mais cavani
3-2 par est super fort aussi en vrai ça
se peut que ce soit fini déjà à ça peut
faire quatre points d'écart sera la
dernière partie de la séquence après on
passe aux trois plus un on a plus un
plus un derrière c'est bien là qu'ils
aient un peu réduit le temps de jeu
d'avants et choper le titre de m me pour
le fun en streaming
non je prends vite perdre mon temps pour
faire ça sol ce rationnement ça va il
reste plus qu'une heure et demie de jeu
derrière je crois pas si long
ça va être long pour nana
des trois c'est la grosse menace 6 à 4
points d'écart c'est quasiment game over
honnêtement vu le scénario du match
ouais je conviens mais plus courts de
dix ou quinze et vingt minutes je crois
les matchs les dires disque a renoncé 20
et qu'est l'e3 ça marche peut-être
encore faut calculer jeu parce que femi
char est pas content d'un truc d'avoir
un voisin où il doit y avoir un oiseau
d'avoir un truc
j'irai voir pendant la pause là c'est la
fin du temps
ouais je sais pas
elle pense et 300 marché vrais amis
schaller préserver bonjour dès la fin de
la partie je vais aller voir ce qui se
passe je pas trop qu'il ya des trois
parce que sur pions prend et afu france
et 3 double échec le montrer a vu que ça
joue pas à fond c'est que ça jouerait
tempo et donc on va récupérer le fou en
b2 et sinon il ya cavaliers france est
un géant prend un f5 et qu'elle prend à
deux ça sans marcher après je sais pas
pourquoi le calcul aussi longtemps elle
doit pas être bien sûr au bol away de fo
prend b2 pardon aux français à avoir
réussi à la rendre la danse est finie
instant teint qualité de plus ben y'a un
pion ça peut peut-être tenir choix bien
ces cinq ici est qu'on peut être content
parce que ça donne la casse des 5
ces 3 g 7 3 et 6 je sais pas ce qu'elle
me michelle shephard ya un truc qui la
soul c'est sûr après des fois elle a
peur de choses sur la table et facile
aux chiens font ça aussi en ferait un
truc qui restait sur la table qui lui
fait peur j'aurai un carton ou quoi qui
peut lui faire peur terrible
bon bon voyager pro f 5 là s'est terminé
devant faut bouger tout huit tours de ce
salaire facile hein
c'est dans la famille elle y aura pas de
famine al cette semaine et ni la semaine
prochaine puisque unis dans deux
semaines d'ailleurs ce que femme est
partie en tournoi pour d4 je sais pas
pourquoi la paperie le pion en fait
bizarre quand ma décision de pas prendre
le pion c'était quand même un pion quoi
a l'air de bien
la gagner celle-là est ton g5 surprise
du pion ok mais au pire les pions prend
1,4 qui on prend des trois déjà qui
était intéressant bon mais ça ça a l'air
d'être cool fait voir mais juste par
curiosité de 3,5 après sur tour des
quatre quand même parce que trois cc ça
ça pourrait forcer pousser les échanges
d'une tour quoi
ok on a parti on arrivé là dedans mais
ça va venir petit à petit
bon bah si simple à gagner pas si simple
à gagner mazet vient de perdre contre 1
2006 lors vraiment ouais c'était sûr
aussi que ça allait trop loin
le top-12 ça troll hockey fih 6 1 mais
c'est dur c'est tournant à ce que je
vous disais c'est ces compétitions c'est
spécial ça n'a pas joué depuis longtemps
et l'appareil juste moins bien elle
arrose 5 et 6 seraient peut-être en juin
m6 à la finition
voyons voir nana est nettement moins
forte 1 fois ci c'est fini cette fois ci
c'était
minet et live sync oh oui ça fait
et l'âge 6 et puis on prend 1,4 ça gagne
tout de suite une pièce ça normalement
elle le voit quand même le clouage il
faut le tuer et après prendre quatre non
elle le voit pas dommage d'avoir raté la
tour en 1 la pièce en 1 quand même mais
ça gagne c'est la peau je vais aller
voir avec le chien ce qui se passe mais
alors à quatre points d'écart c'est
quasi un quasi match gagné pour katia à
mon avis si elle trouve pas la
domination
ouais non j'ai pas réussi à re voir ce
qui se passait web on voit quatre points
d'écart web on va voir il reste il reste
encore quoi une heure et demie de match
mais eux
bref vu le scénario ça a l'air de bien
se passer a tant défaut que vous met une
pub attendait ce que je vais réussir à
le faire
[Musique]
mais merde merde
attendez une petite seconde on est
quatre à quatre points d'écart la scène
c'est proche d'être terminée
ouais je les coachs et le chien
sa lé coach le chien
donc
tranquillement regarder la deuxième
partie du match en a pas on va pas se
mettre la pression on va regarder paix
pouzin on va regarder ça paie pouzin 1,5
du peloton substance aux bruins permet
de mettre la petite pub bon voilà un se
passe pas grand chose on est bien on est
tranquille 1
on est tranquille
on attend on attend que ça se passe un
ça va être combien de temps et je crois
que c'est sûr que c'est 50 minutes 45
minutes
au quart d'heure de 3,5 et après 25
minutes de bull est quand même ça soit
le truc le plus important ça permettra
peut-être à hikaru de gagner le speech
est mixte
c'est moi chagrine maso a pris ses goûts
c'est sur facebook on peut voir ça
donc
sur sa chaise comme je les games
donc je sais je regarde la game de maso
en fait
qui peut perdre c'est beau ça quand même
je regardais la game 2 de femmes mois
fabre qui sut est un peu de jouer
cherche maso
ces prix une fourchette en deux
ils jouent contre émile
comment il a perdu sa pièce
je regarde un art in rdc pris une
fourchette intérim a été
prix une fourchette
ouais c'est terrible la fonction comme
asos est pris c'est terrible mais contre
émile ouais bah il faut pas mal et 1000
il joue pas mal j'attends un petit coup
d'oeil avant de regarder c'est parti
effarant jette un petit coup d'oeil à
fabas vendent avant de revenir là dessus
pendant l'été ou fab fab il était là il
fut contraint 2003 fab m sans
adversaires à plus de temps après la
position est compliqué ça saoule et fab
il va en à kiev
mazeau yves arnaque est vrai je penserai
c'est de nouveau une sicilienne et elle
est repartie dans les choix schennikov
katia mellal améliorer mais c'est fou
quand la fouchette capri maso c'est
quand même terrible
bon allez frais katia on va remettre
l'échiquier du bon côté pour avoir la
tête des joueuses à côté de de la
position
caron
voir si nana réussi à faire mieux
masoe thème à l'avant de ce complexe roi
fuite c'est pas bizarre dans le sens où
il va y avoir h 4 h 5 et que le roi sera
mal placées après d'un autre côté savais
que ça n'enlève des fous ces quatre mais
elle prend déjà trop de temps nana elle
prend beaucoup trop de temps à n'a donc
aller dans le très dur à la 10e minute
de retard qu'a tient en fait à la
compris elle joue vite elle se dit que l
arnaque rats toujours généralement quand
les matches sont comme ça ça va raquer
savent arnaquer tout le long déjà une
trempe davance position sympa elle tient
la casse des 5
la position est complexe à
va revenir en trois on va tenir à des
cases et puis on va échanger en c4 et
attaqué des six ça va le faire pour
katia katia qui peut prendre cinq points
d'avancé mais ouais on va commencer à
être bien sûr quand même qu'elle est
plus forte
je suis pas sûr qu'on soit vraiment sûr
à la fin ou la bizarre ki67 c'est le
cavalier un peu dans un no man's land
quoi on est roi il était solide y
contrôler énormément de cases
importantes notamment la cage et cat way
et là il n'ya pas de tour f1 y avait eu
2 ou la caisse et 7 c mais visuellement
ça se voit que c'est un coup de chaud
hot le carélien retrouvailles contrôler
f1 une contrôler g4g 2 il protégeait le
fou c4 il était bien mais bon une
nouvelle fois on l a voulu jouer vital a
eu un mauvais réflexe mais voilà c'est
une minute vendent avance et à et nana
qui est incapable d'accélérer donc ouais
ce match terminé les amis
[Musique]
j'annonce victoire de katia à 100% mais
c'est pas possible si quant à 40
secondes tu tant que tu te rendes 30
secondes dans cette position il faut
arrêter quoi tu gagneras jamais en fait
c'est impossible
katia qui joue bien elle joue à zhuhai
où le bateau a ajouté mme peau elle peut
prendre hd ya pas de maths du couloir
elle contrôlait fin mais elle peut aussi
faire tour f 1 qui peut être tentant
mais touré fait un tour achats
elle a fait maintenant à 3 tranquille
ouah deux dames prend des 4 ok donc père
matériellement ses pions plus pour les
noirs mais c'est ouais c'est pas clair
réussissent à la tête du bon coup la
nana l'avait pu calculer en amont les
coûts et là elle se remet à réfléchir
donc c'est dead
allez si elle voit cavaliers prend roi
prend fou des 3l gagne et la ja qui a
ébranlé 8 ouais ben ouais c'est du
trolling c'est du trolling ça c'était du
trolling m d'un briquet prandelli
trolling ouais ça troll un peu quoi
ça tremble un peu
bayer menace la menace la dame prendrait
de maths à s'est pas vu terrible ça
troll ça troll madame b 8 buts rowling
quand même alors qu'elles franchissaient
dessous des 3 d'un projet 6 gagner
instantanément table ouais c'est beau
elles ont calé l'ol sont 2500 à peu près
en fidèles à tuer leurs lots de chasse
comme 2006 2007
quel processus du coup elle se vengera
sur ces 3 un policier est absolument
symétrique
un troll
et la partie de fab en fait c'est vrai
que du coup le top 12 est pas mal pour
regarder en multiplex quoi j'avais
sous-estimé en fait j'avais sous-estimé
le l'intérêt du top 12 en fait partie
favret famille la 32e minute quand même
il m'avait dit qu'il essaierait de jouer
vite donc il suit le précepte un an mal
an ça doit tout échange et ça doit être
égal
oui tout à fait mais là c'est pas des
beaux tournois jumper en fait je regarde
pas parce que c'est un pote mais en vrai
fab lui-même il s'en fiche de son
résultat c'est ça qui est beau c'est que
je sais ça qu'on vous explique en fait
ça joue pour rien quoi ça joue pour rien
si ça joue mais en fait qui est une
équipe où nos dix fois championne de
france
c'est pas ça change pas live de fabre
quand ils sont en vrai c'est pas c'est
vrai c'est pas un grand truc quoi
f3
f3 plutôt qu'un échange est bon tout ça
c'est du grand classique 1 de ce genre
de position avec les fous qui
s'échangent j'avais vont prendre en b 7
à 8
c'est vraiment al hakim et les pubs 1
cette chaise comme kim et les pubs je
crois qu'il doit y avoir six minutes de
plus par heure
grosso modo que vous sachiez à quoi vous
attendre
voilà ça échanges devraient normalement
ça ça fait nul mais bon sait jamais
ça va échanger en c1
enfin sage
pas pour le moment
sur la partie de base et à aimer à 0
n'ont probablement il ya un problème de
retransmission des femmes qui a joué
ce parti doit finir en une vraie
je pense que fab prendre un avantage ici
voit ce que dit la turbine chez faber
est en fait le coup de la turbine ce
forcément le coup que fab a vu ça
devrait aller pour fab pas sur ce que tu
auras pas sûr
pas sûr pas sûr avec la turbine on voit
que les vannes mais je suis pas sûr en
fait
et c'est pas sûr encore pour fab est ici
il se passe quoi les blancs ont pris
l'avantagé mais du coup le match a pu
peut-être un peu tourné 1
la turbine c'est le redis un petit ordi
qui donne qui donne les meilleurs enfin
les meilleurs poulet ou sans sel bon en
fait le coup le plus logique pour fab
semble être bon après je comprends pas
pourquoi une variante je n'arrive pas à
comprendre pourquoi donc je me dis pas
sûr qu'il trouve quoi voilà ça
faire du lin normalement c'est les noirs
qui devrait gagner parce que
la joueuse géorgienne se fout dans la
merde autant mais après voilà c'est
n'importe quoi c'est aussi ça paraît
tellement bizarre de laisser ça ça a
l'air de foule troll de nouveaux
terrible bon je suis pas qui va gagner
salaire de fou troll complexe c'est être
les blancs qui vont gagner la tour des
huit noms au sa tombe avec ma tante 3o
quelle horreur il y avait tout reprend
g63 à schwyz où ces trois matt hall a
raté ma tondeuse
c'est terrible de tomber avec ma
tondeuse aussi impressionnant les amis
c'est pas possible
elle est tombée avec ton pranger 6e qui
était seul coup et fous ces trois assez
terrible de tomber là dessus à 7
et de tomber là dessus pour nana au elle
tomba m'attend de quoi en plus c'est
étrange et si c'était obligé de faire
les fous ces trois échecs après c'était
à sa l'option elle avait quand même 3
secondes et demie pour le faire ah ouais
non là c'est un nouveau tournant du
match
mais bon après ça équilibre katia qui a
jeté complètement gagnant donner une
dame en un hélas elle jette complètement
gagnant elle rate m'attendent au gré des
rebondissements dans ce match non ce
rôle m'a tendu comme ça avec le plus 1
seconde c'est vraiment terrible
j'imagine à 700m non mais j'imagine un
mais c'est terrible
le troll de nana je regarde la partie de
faillite fait autre façon là ça se joue
vraiment c'est parti là ça se joue à la
fin comme ça peut donner des dames en 1
et et raté des maths en deux on s'attend
à tout
mais la nana qui reprend encore une
minute dans l'ouverture et non c'est
assez catastrophique
je sais pas pourquoi vous me demandez
pourquoi la rade comme ça ils sont juste
moins forte c'est tout que tu mets une
pôle gare pour prendre l'exemple d'une
femme elle le voit instantanément sa
peau le garant blitz elle était
monstrueuse donc c'est juste une
question niveau là c'est juste une
question niveau ce pas une question
d'hommes de femmes ou de quoi que ce
soit c'est juste que c'est 2006 chaise
comme ces 2006 chez scor en fait un face
et ça tient même pour l'essab web à
rouiba les sablés ce battle ça peut
préparer ouais c'est une question niveau
en fait hein c'est juste une question de
level 1 pas une question d'un bout de
femme en ici tu prends
avec le même classement il fait les
mêmes erreurs une question de level
là rien de mal un jeu pensé f5 qui s'y
installent mans thématique ça va tu as
une question de stress bref pour ça
quand des fois où on dit on se bat hull
à waimes à quinson comment tu fais cette
erreur enfin là on a quand même une
joueuse professionnelle qui est 2500
fidh qui file c'est vraiment son métier
quoi
elle peut vraiment facilement vivre des
échecs et ça ça rate des maths en deux
comme ça quoi donc au bout d'un moment
ça conduit à 15 cents comment il a raté
sa machin baron funa la mi na na na waie
c'est la même quoi ya pas de baron fou
qui tienne
g4 avala ya un pion pranger cette cavale
a raté au nom elle a raté aussi allez
peut-être ça gagne aussi mes pions
pranger cette saga nier un centre qui
épreuve deux pions profite prise f2 et
c'était ouais mais là c'est quoi ton
gagnant aussi un prénom
elle avait le choix du riche alors pas
de bol de pas avoir dame prend 5
puisqu'il ya tours 8
c'est pas de bol donc elle fait fourrer
sa mère jouée et heureusement que la
donne et la dame 1 katia sinon ça ferait
on serait déjà là on est à + 4 on serait
déjà plus s'ils souhaitent bon elle va
normalement gagné très facilement katia
ici
en 1700 sur une femme est là où il voit
le hello une femme qui a deux mille cinq
cents lots joue au même niveau qu'un
homme qui a deux mille cinq cents lots
ya aucune différence mal autant je suis
pas sûr c'était terreur de
retransmission sur la partie de fab
c'est peut-être une erreur de temps en
tout cas katia katia montre qu'elle est
vraiment sereine cliente 1 dans ce dans
cette compétition là y'a pas fou prend
2,5 encore je pense dans la n'avais
vraiment aucune chance bien joué là ce
qu'elle fait mais il va y avoir ces
signes qu ici ans elle va fermer bien
joué et katia fois moi j'ai pas de
couple vous avez un coup après le a6 ou
pas dans la partie du fab g5
et à l'est la turquie par an 1
parfaitement joué il a fait f4
nathan arrivons à cette vallée qui
arrive à arriver en d6 aller katia ça
fait plus cinq et elle relègue son
adversaire en dessous des 2600 là ça a
été une ni deux et demi nana qui change
qui par produire quatre grandes
théorique
en ce genre de variantes avec le 5,44
maso conduite merlet mais c'est beau
aussi maso perd contre émile serait
quand même très très drôle hein bazot
ses seuls gains en toute amitié est
acasiens wii qui perdent en fait en tant
qu'allemand vie qui campe ce que c'est
un pote mais s'il perd tu dit la légende
continue quoi
c'est un des soldats ou quelque part le
défaite participe à sa légende
non mais vraiment en fait un genre des
fêtes de mazo ne touche pas sa légende
il a quand même tout à mais il a toutes
les cases noires en plus on voit toutes
les cases noires maso il est incroyable
mazeau c'est le gars capable de battre
thomas chef ce qui est un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde deux en technique et de
le battre sur son territoire et qui est
capable dans la partie d'après de perdre
contre un joueur complètement amateur à
2000 et lokua c'est vraiment la star
maso
eiffage et plus les coûts la nana c'est
victoire obligatoire 1 défaite ici c'est
plus 6
tactique g5 avec 4 terminal la combine
que maso s'est pris à les incroyables
quoi moi j'ai pas les coûts de la partie
de femmes c'est ça c'est embêtant
tiens red one qui jours et doit maths ou
grand il a joué le f4 autsai et je lai
m
la fois trop de femmes
bon c'est chaud à partie de fab
je pense qu'il va gagner quand même
ce qui arriva pour commencer à être en
contrôle voilà et dans ce match il se
passe quoi
fallu jean top 12 contres qu'on contre
un gars en fait
mais là il commencera et commence à être
bien le fable fera va gagner ouais c'est
première bonne nouvelle
le fab en forme
et ici est-ce que nana se retrouve mal
autant elle elle se fout mal autant
comme d'hab
ça peut troll ça me tenait sa défaite de
mazet mais maso peut vraiment la perdre
assez exceptionnel
na comment elle se fait arnaquer cette
fois ci elle sert foutu vraiment mal
autant elle sert foutu très mal autant
nana y avait une chanson de tan tan
nanani nanana filet fut gees non
nananana c'était quoi déjà cette chanson
je pense c'était les fugees mais à les
paroles me reviennent pas mais avait dû
aux nanas n'a peut-être pas un j'en sais
rien ouais là les fuji ouais je pensais
que c'était aux nanas dans fable
complètement gagnant
mais la petite défaite de mazo peut se
présenter
alors comment est-ce qu'on perce à la
masterpiece en route côté na na battue
cette chanson blair est fantastique
j'adore les fugees
mais je pense ma chanson préférée les
fidjis et killing me softly fantastique
killing me softly bon allez il faut
prendre les rois g6 je connais pas trop
les paroles mais bon on tente pour l est
pas passé avec au f5 mère delphine filet
ok ça trop loin
pourquoi l'a pas pris d'options à la
paperie à 5h comprend rien elle va à
dame
c'est terrible à ces terribles au sas à
troller côté nana fous ces trois le pion
actif il ne savait pas comment aider à
perdre mais on a trouvé
elle peut abandonner là on sort l'ina
on savait pas comment ça allait perdre
mais on savait que ça allait perdre
c'est bien là le plus important
c'est à annoncer un ouais mais quand tu
commences à perdre toutes les parties
c'est dur en fait ouais une voix de
matthew bellamy vrai nom mais quand tu
qu enfin je trouve que c'est quand tu
perds des positions aussi simple il fait
tu peux rien faire en fait en vrai 100
points sur chaise comme c'est un gros
écart et la savoie à l'essence 58 ans de
défaites avec nana terrible alors je
suis super mais les anciennes versions
qui est mis sa fille sont très cool
aussi ouais c'est vrai aussi
sans agression sauvage c'est comment on
a va perdre on prends moi j'aime bien
les petits matches comme ça je suis pas
votre image pas serré comme ça je trouve
ça fait plaisir je pas ce que vous en
pensez
moi je trouve ça un kiff les petits
matches comme ça tranquille ou épouses
tu regardes tu sais ce qui va se passer
et tu vas tu as pas le côté stress
j'ai peur - tu as
n'a pas le côté vibrations ouais c'est
ça les enfants de hiérarchie d'ordre
ouais c'est ça tu passes tu passes 3
heures à faire défoncer en bout et puis
il ya pas de côté stress quoi la cata
qui gagne tranquille wipitta le côté
aussi comment est ce qu'elle va perdre
quelques coups de merde on va avoir dans
cette partie et où ses graffs cool en
vrai andré franchement c'est hyper
reposant des matches comme ça pas
vraiment jamais besoin de t'emballer
c'est c'est très très tranquille
ouais c'est ça c'est complètement en
mode des stress quoi tu vois un peu de
coûts passent et sa clique vraiment
totalement au hasard
voilà pas pris des quatre parce qu'elle
se dit que le pion en fait il n'ya pas
grand chose et il est un peu à la merci
des blancs tu es tranquille
c'est avec sandra ça risque d'être beau
ça peut être plus serrée ouais c'est
cool ou qu'on a quand même vu en plus on
a eu un bel enchaînement m'attend de
rater into d'abandonner aussi sympa
j'invite le ton et les chics hier une
nouvelle fois en fait j'en ai marre
d'être tout le temps du côté de nana au
niveau de l'échiquier ça me saoule un
peu je suis content d'être un peu côté
cathy avons va rester cotée katia avec
les blancs long virage avait envie de
voir une fois une partie côté katia quoi
j'en ai marre d'être du côté loser
on est bien on est tranquille on a entre
nous à la bonne
non on a peut-être sous-estimé le format
speech est en fait être le but du format
c'est justement lors des matchs pekouz
où il se passe
r en fait et où tu regarde vraiment
comme ça en tout deposit et quoi il ya
peut-être un intérêt là dedans un verre
inversée les webcams en fait ça prend
trois minutes à chaque fois d inverser
et le temps de les ré inverser de tours
est inversée en fait pour autant de
temps que la partie
ouais c'est de la smr échec
en fait c'est de la smr tout court je
pense
adam prend b2 on ferme la dame petits
pièges mais qui peut passer à ce niveau
c'est fou la smr en fait
un concept une fois je me prends une
petite piscine gonflable pour commenter
alors fab c'est game un fab ça gagne
bref c'est fini
mazeau il va perdre peut-être c'est le
moment de proposer nul pour maso a
espéré à prendre un demi point en fait
on doit faire en fait en fait si je suis
assez content du déroulement du match en
vrai je laissais vraiment tranquille ou
en vrai c'est vraiment tranquille
res canada va la perdre peut-être un
difficile avec le roi noir ici
mon père l'imposition des choses en fait
mais je pense que les preuves c'est vrai
bien joué de la part de la main au
canada va peut-être pas perdre ici
ouais
c'est récupéré des cinq si elle peut ça
sent que c'est pas terrible à ce qu'elle
fait ça sans que les pièces blanches
sont sur des mauvaises passes d'un an
je pense et nana qui va gagner
la nana peut la gagner celle-là quoique
ce qu'elle peut encore merdé ouais en
fait à la tête mr des nanas lci mal
autant plus assez terrible ouais ça
échange des dames et a du coup sans voix
dessins que si c'est terrible un anad ça
va ça file à dam
et ça fait plus être dans ce match
terrible
annoncé durant ces sept points d'écart
le match est déjà plié tu vois tu dois
encore jouer à 40 minutes s'est passé
complexe et un côté na na pas forcément
agréable quoi ce que ça troll un peu
quand même côté côté maso on n'est pas
encore bien sûr en vrai ouais après
après une heure de jeu on sentait quand
même format 7 est quand même bien plus
approprié au spectacle mais bon là on
est sur un an et sur un format de type à
smr paru si impressionné je fais
catastrophe mondiale non non non là il
ya vraiment on sent que man a fait des
faits des fins dans le niveau de jeu
allait pas loin mais elle est là un
problème de vitesse en fait vu qu'elle
peut pas jouer vite c'est un peu
inéluctable elle peut pas vendre une
machine ans est interdite obligés
d'aller jusqu'au bout et du coup on va
on va jusqu'au bout un pour être bien
sûr quand même mais mathématiquement
c'est déjà quasiment terminé peut-être
qu'en vingt +5 ou en quinze plus elle
serait beaucoup plus forte voix d'anna
là on sent que c'est pas sa cadence
c'est qu'on reste il joue pas je laisse
tomber est a pas vraiment le droit
le droit de le faire malheureusement
peut-être d'ailleurs t'as envie en fait
juste de rage quit 1
sa santé un katia était plus forte ça
s'est senti quand il ya eu trois et demi
à un ennemi ou quelque chose comme ça
quand elle a gagné la partie + 3g une
partie où on a senti vraiment que ça
pousse et la partie où elle avait une
tour de moins net vous rappeler cette
partie onana avait une tour de plus
nette elle avait l'activité est ce que
vous vous rappelez de cette partie une
partie vous ai dit le match est terminé
ce que ça soit avec nana elle avait un
problème à jouer trop lentement elle a
commencé à se faire arnaquer avec une
tour de plus et en fait ça s'est vu
quand elle a perdu sa queue s'était pas
ce n'est pas un hasard en fait elle
s'était mis dans la merde tout seul je
vous l'avais dit elle avait réussi à
perdre un truc mais vraiment imperdable
et sa santé que ça allait pas être la
dernière fois
well as passé une minute pour alors la
page x 3 la joue un autre coup forme
elle avait le choix entre deux trois
coups super fort et elle avait une tour
de plus elle a pris une minute pour
prendre sa décision et sa santé que
ben quand tu fais ce genre de choses
c'est que tu vas perdre en fait il n'ya
pas de monde où tu gagnes un match où tu
trolles pas de d'une telle manière en
vrai en occasion un niveau similaire à
katia un peu plus forte aux siens
mais du coup après peut-être
qu'intrinsèquement à l'est déjà moins
forte en blitz et qu'elle a et qu'elle
prend trop de temps qu'un lapin
bourrique de réflexion mais en plus si
elle fait ce genre d'erreurs et qu'en
plus elle perd et qu elle le paye cash
immédiatement bas c'est la spirale
infernale qui débute un c'est un tournoi
exhibition h
ok donc là c'est les quarts de finale
d'une compétition exhibition
prize pool oui oui mais price foule
comme dans n'importe quelle compétition
d'exhibition d'exhibition ne veut pas
dire absence de prize pool presque pas
mal ckt apprennent un huitième point
d'avancé histoire d'être cannes bien sûr
est que le mal soit mathématiquement
plié avant les bullet histoire de
s'éviter à une fausse frayeur côté katia
ya pas la mission suggère lagarde web
alors après le switch agirait socir à un
tournoi exhibition après je crois qu'il
avait enlevé ça parce que le le problème
c'est que quand ils l'ont fait après les
filles il y avait eu danielian que je
contenais paume à chaque fois elle
prenait 28 à 2,29 à 1 et on voyait que
les adversaires paris scrute n'est pas
parce qu'on peut pas les retenir mais
que ça pouvait faire du 30 03 et du coup
c'était bien agréable pour les
spectateurs ni pour eux ni pour les
joueurs en fait
disons qu'on n'est pas là pour ce à quoi
s'est un peu humiliant enfin c'est pas
une question d' humiliant rien mais
c'est inconfortable
la nana est bien de nouveaux jeux pas si
elle va troll ces questions comme cheikh
strasbourg et non j'ai pas de strasbourg
mais je pense qu'il ya des bons des bons
clubs dans en alsace généralement il ya
des bons clubs en ce qu'elle va jouer
dame e6
hayatou reprend 2,2 à elle a raté ton
proche de dame prend des cinq la petite
tactique qui gagne un pion net
ça commence à troll ouais c'est gros
troll en avoir après ça de la part de
katia pas trop réfléchir la côte et
katia clément h6 je pense fallait pas
donner ça tellement mal joué mais ce
qu'elle peut la tenir quand même elle a
bien joué à nana elle va faire b5 ici
mais nan a très bien joué ici elle va
porter well as raté tout reprend 2 katia
est l'arrivée adam prend b2 roy price 5
c'était bien joué noël
tampon 2 qui gagne est un pion et la
partie sur le champ les masos comment ça
se passe ces années un parti de la
cadence je pense pas qu'ils perdent maso
je pense pas qu'ils perdent et fab a
gagné suspense est complètement relancé
à barouhio alors bondé car tout peut
arriver
mais oui c'est un peu un peu trop le
côté côté katia mepha belle victoire
contre un joueur à 2300 il rentre bien
dans le tournoi
alors ça y est le temps qui va en voir
la petite sonnerie on va se rencontrer
c'est vraiment on se croirait au top au
top 14
choses sublimes sans rire on va avoir un
petit vlad ambulants qui va passer
shingle ecoplus ouais voilà katia encore
en train de faire n'importe quoi
j'ai l'impression le tour prend des
trois dames 1 dames eux deux c'est pas
terrible mais bon ça arrive dans la
partie précédente elle a raté une telle
occasion
f2 aa terrible raté sa terrible de rater
car et les f2 fallait juste faire fou ou
trois ans c'était pas terrible mais
fallait juste faire [ __ ] trois quarts
aile et pour trois tours 33 cet avantage
cet avantage avantages vont quand même
mais la roue à chien cavalière de
barrois ger 1 cavalia je crois bouger
dame germes at elle a laissé ma tante 3e
bon bah écoute et on va se faire une
petite pause un petit pub évidemment
faux 3 5 mille cinq cents lots ouais peu
près vrai s'en va une petite pub et on
revient après
je peux pas envoyer la pub si hockey tu
vas de suite les gars
les gars ça va reprendre il ya le shaq
il
bien qu'il ait fait de la merde je mange
de petites tomates
[Musique]
j'arrive manche de petites tomates genre
yves lacam je n'aime pas manger quand je
la cam - c'est parti pour les bulles est
à cinq points d'écart donc trois cas que
25 minutes cette année dommage qu'il
n'ait pas mis 20 minutes en fait c'est
le la cadence qui demande le moins
baissé
donc il ya combien de partis sur 25
minutes sur 25 minutes qui devait voir
huit parties cette partie désolé incité
le temps de le finir cette petite tomate
qui a fait plaisir et nana qui est déjà
en difficulté elle met trop de temps là
ça s'est vraiment mal joué de sa part
d'avoir déjà à 30 secondes de retard et
katia qui fait le taf
résultat un rush et anaïs est
intéressant de te voir pour voir les
échecs écoute merci à toi il manque
merci à toi quelqu'un qui doit jouer la
pendule après donc non ça devrait gagner
tranquille là pour katia c'est pour moi
c'est du 100% perdre un tel match serait
une catastrophe pour katia tu peux pas
perdre ça en fait tu domines le match tu
joues plus vite
vrai en plus c'est parti que nana va
gagner elles vont forcément durée parce
qu'elles seraient mal autant elle peut
pas gagner deux parties vraiment vite à
mon avis est donc ouais ouais non le
match le match est complètement dans
l'est dans les mains de katia juste ne
pas ne pas faire n'importe quoi ça
échange ale faut rentrer peut-être dans
la finale de cavaliers au pire ça fera
perdre beaucoup de temps on est déjà à
quoi à deux minutes et quelques de jeu
comme ça ça peut jouer pendant encore
deux trois minutes
avec l'arabe le rajout d'une seconde
peut y avoir vraiment beaucoup de coups
dans jour de finale ça c'est forcément
en faveur de katia elle va faire à 5 b
si je pense ici
forcément sa faveur là bas on va
dépasser les tongs cic trois minutes de
jeu c'était vrai 8,9 partie mais on sait
que souvent ça dépasse les 3 minutes les
parties avoir un bon exemple ici
directement
normalement elle va pas jouer la finale
deux pions à l'y obligeait
ok intéressant elle obligée de rentrer
dans la finale de purée normalement tu
as pas très envie parce qu'il ya un
problème d' espaces après normalement tu
joues le miroir ici quel âge 6 mai car
du coup ses pions prend roi des six il
va falloir fermer la porte
normalement c'est drôle mais vous l'avez
dit à ces parties durent longtemps
attention nana qui peut tomber mme
marois c'est si ça l'est toujours un peu
plus vite la côte et katia nul est
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour elle
nul nul en trois minutes 45 forcément
une bonne nouvelle ça enlève une partie
ça lui laisse le plus 5 est maintenant
une victoire est peut-être déjà décisive
maintenant une victoire et peut-être
aller aller à une victoire 1 nul pour
catia et se termine à dos elle est à un
point et demi katia main tendue du match
k
comment ça va
vance et la tia kia qui est pas acquis a
pas eu de très bonnes positions à danser
dans ces attaques grand prix des tarifs
6 ici maintenant ça paraît risqué m6 m6
puis on prend danger car tu préfèrerais
bien joué un en-tête du c4 g4 g5 c'était
un peu bizarre quand même mais bon c'est
du bullet un nom qu'on en voit un peu
comme on peut on va peut-être mettre la
tour sur f2 j'ai toujours un oeil aux
chronos plus que 20 minutes
sûrement faire tour c1
cette position est mieux contrôlée par
nana que la position précédente réussi à
jouer plus vite mais bon katia qui
envoie le pion parce qu'elle veut à elle
veut tout reprend ses deux tours
précédents et tour c'est un tour c'est 8
à la fin pas mal joué elle envoie h 4 h
5 maintenant il faut les gagner cette
partie est encore une et ce sera terminé
il faudra mieux jouer un cependant pour
battre whif à nous-mêmes ou même
kosteniuk c'était un peu léger 1 dames
f7 c'est logique à elle veut tous rêvent
de tourtour h2 s'apprend g6
elle va reprendre et elle va faire dame
17,3 g2j magie mais adam g4 ici à la
rate et ont raté parler de faux d'amazon
dame proche cathy si bien joué katia m
c'était dur à voir le dame g4 ont eu
l'aide quand c'est ouais quand tu es
dans le feu de l'action
c'était très dur l apparente règles d'un
match 8
allez tour c1 c'est un bon cours ça
rentre ans et 8
sahnoun is la tour allait peut-être fou
b4 fou prend non elle revient c'est
laborieux un côté blanc allait peut-être
d'un match fou de foot b4 ça donne envie
détourage 6 donne envie aussi fou b4
échec non elle a échangé
elle n'a pas vu le fou b4 mais elle va
réussir à être en d4 bien joué et ça
gagne autant bien jouer katia partir en
plus qui a duré donc là il ya quoi il ya
six points d'écart 17 minutes ou à une
victoire c'est sûr que ça termine le
match
katia qui aurait été facile on n'aura
pas vraiment eu de suspense dans ce
match il n'y aura pas vraiment eu de
suspense les amis on peut le dire
j'ai pas si si vous vous avez vous avez
vu du suspense
après il y avait là donc il vient on
invite est maintenant visible maintenant
sûr
sueur
bon
ce que savard est là elle s'est remise
mal autant elle s'est remis très mal
autant et donc apprendre à voir du wlan
ambulants qui va qui va arriver
ces atouts qui ont accueilli ces trois
maintenant et prend 1,3 ray terrible qui
essaient 3 qui prend des 1
tombé huit tours b 2e tour b encore
mieux jouer bien vraie cata en effet
adam eve 2 je pense termine le truc
et oui allez encore fous ces cas très
bon cette fois ci c'est terminé c'est
sûr mathématiquement c'est fini plus 7
15 minutes terribles
terim c'est réellement terrible on va
pour envoyer quelques blitz avec avec
vlad du coup ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisir
je vais commencer à mettre le titre est
tout
hop je passerai j'aimerais voir passer
aux choses sérieuses à on était bien
cool ce match mais il est temps qu'il
est temps que sa fille soit on reste
encore 15 minutes y'a plus grand chose à
dire le match est plié face au mas la
chaîne si si si on va on va voir on doit
attendre que ça finisse mais là je vais
me remettre directement la pub
d'ailleurs ce qu'il faut mettre encore
une cuve de trois minutes pour être bien
sûr on va enfin tron va être tranquille
ou 1
on est bien sûr au moins
bien sûr le match après bon il était à
sens unique 1 le match était
complètement à sens unique
ouais en fait y'a pas vraiment faim n'y
avait pas vraiment de suspens parce que
parce que très vite c'est luc attia été
beaucoup plus forte quoi voilà l apr il
faut faire attention ne pas reconduire
food et 4 elle a raté je pense de base
cèdent pas rater mais ça fait un peu
peur
là normalement il ya plus de monde où
elle perd ce match
bref 5 ouais ouais nana qui tombe même
site c'est en fait on le savait dès le
moment qu'on sait que ça va se passer
comme ça en fait en vrai
en vrai ça fait longtemps un compte
c'est là il ya huit points d'écart ouais
c'était vraiment un match sans saveur
arrive
terrible pincez vlad qui arrive
elle a largement gagné deux matches
après par contre avant de donner leur
diable a déjà joué deux buts parce que
là c'est là c'est trop la la ça m'a trop
frustrée elle a pas fait cavaler l a pas
vu la dame en 1re assez terrible c'est
terrible complexe çà il prend aussi ce
qui est restée pendant trois quatre
coups sur l'échiquier
non pour me nettoyer l'esprit j'ai envie
d'envoyer 2 3bis quand même parce que là
c'est complexe reste encore dix minutes
je serai pas joué ouais ouais ouais
ouais fruste pas frustrant un match
comme ça c'est très frustrant c'est très
frustrant on va avoir deux d'affilée
demain ça va être terrible
enfin je vais en avoir 2 vous n'êtes pas
vous n'êtes pas obligé de venir et de
d'affilée ça va être terrible
bien sûr qu'on viendra vous êtes maso
les gars je soutiens moralement mais ce
que sarah mater samassa les reste encore
neuf minutes
naseaux tire bien je vais les regarder
les parties de ma zone
en attendant je vous tenir au courant je
laisse ça en fond et je vais vous dire
ce qui se passe chez maso et on va on va
faire ça c'est pas un prix met autant de
pub d'ailleurs honnêtement je n'ai
aucune idée je vais voir ce qui se passe
côté mazet et il va probablement la
tenir
va sûrement la tenir non mais les gars
là le match est fini en fait ya pu rien
à voir enfin il ya 13 il ya 13 à 6 c'est
gagner quoi déjà c'est injuste on a le
match et est terminée quoi
mais amazon
mon femme qui a gagné et y avait ni
maxime une personne qui ferait à
pourquoi jouent elles sont obligées en
fait dans le règlement le match est
terminé elles sont justes obligé de
continuer mais il n'y a aucun
mathématiquement c'est perdu déjà c'est
fini en fait c'est évident la règle du
match en fait tu es obligé de jouer
jusqu'au bout même si tu as déjà perdu
mais là ça fait déjà on va dire 20
ça fait vingt minutes qu'elle a déjà
perdu en vrai et ça fait à peu près une
heure une heure et demi qu'on n'est sûr
à quatre entre ok ça fait une heure
qu'on est sûrs à 98% l'issue du match et
ça fait et ça fait une vingtaine de
minutes cas-là mathématiquement perdu
katia théoriquement il pourrait partir
de l'ordinateur et arrêter le match mais
si elle voulait après c'est pas très
fair play mais elle pourrait le faire
le format équivalent à 10 très mauvais
au pdg de jazz comme abbaoui maxime
quant à l'effet interview il avait dit
que c'était très mauvais forme à
s'effacer clair et évident il suffit de
voir de regarder quelques matchs et tu
vois tout de suite que ça va pas c'est
comment se bat alors ouais mais ça c'est
parce qu'on veut faire plaisir aux aux
auditeurs zoug
mais en soi ah tiens la rate et qui
avait un fils ici si ça va encore gagner
pour katia mais en soi quand il ya des
gros écarts on aura juste les parties
comme ça on les regarde plus vraiment
non plus hein
mais au nom même les joueurs il n'aime
pas trop en fait le format je sais pas
je sais pas je sais un mystère pour moi
pourquoi ce format perdure les mêmes
même
même les joueurs sont pas failli ce pas
parce que du coup là tu vas y à beaucoup
de matches qui sont comme ça et là par
exemple pour nana c'est hyper chiant
pour pour katia aussi mais quand tu
gagnes bon juste assidus fini le truc
mais pour nana c'est c'est hyper relou
de devoir vrai
et c'est normal quoi c'est hyper chiant
tu as déjà perdu tout objet de devoir
continuer à cliquer machin ça dure
longtemps
c'est pas agréable c'est justement aussi
pour ça que celui qui perd à m'ont donné
commence à vraiment mal joué lalart
atteint une dame en 1 elle a raté
beaucoup de choses nana
c'est clairement c'est clairement
difficile ouais c'est clairement
désagréable pour pour la joueuse
l'idée alors c'est pas de favre n'en
l'idée je crois fondamentalement que
l'idée c'est d'avoir un format calais
pour pour les pubs en fait je suppose je
ne sais pas mais je suppose que c'est un
rapport avec ça pour savoir combien de
temps le match et combien de de pub de
pub y aura pour pour les diffuseurs mais
pour les joueurs c'est pour les joueurs
et pour le public c'est pas très
agréable moi j'avais d'ailleurs refusé
la compétition il m'avait invité avec ce
format j'avais juste refusé de jouer
parce que c'est insupportable c'est
insupportable de jouer donc j'avais
j'avais décliné l'invitation
et si j'ai été réinvité pour retourner
avec un format similaire à moins qu'ils
aient vraiment un prize pool énorme et
que du coup un bon bah ça se refuse pas
mais à
[Musique]
mes meilleurs or prize pool exceptionnel
c'est impossible que je vois un truc
pareil
ouais non j'avais refusé j'avais refusé
j'avais bien fait je suis très content
d'avoir refusé ce coup je dirais ça fera
peut-être un event c'est peut-être un
peu marrant et tous puis après je suis à
temps mais j'ai pas envie de vous un
truc pareil quand même et est du coup
bah j'avais refusé j'en étais j'en suis
assez content on voit que katia attend
un de faire un peu défiler le temps je
pense les deux joueuses espèrent arriver
au bout du timer là les deux jouent là
les deux joueuses en ont maintenant
elles ont toutes les deux envie d'en
finir c'est sûr elle vous par obligation
ça envoie un petit peu quoi mais bon
avant de voir là tu va également envoyer
2 3 4 bis cela devient long et 2 3 4 bis
histoire de la frustration est trop
grande
enfin bien pour des ordis vrai et après
en plus ce qui est bizarre avec ce
format c'est que je me rends compte
qu'il ya plus il ya eu plus de bulles
est que dresse n'ont au final
ouais non c'est à peu près pareil wes à
peu près équilibré mais l'importance du
bullet et quand même grande c'est pour
ça que c'était vrai c'est sûr que katia
prendrait le dessus après elle a
vraiment gagné sur ses qualités de
glisseuse 1
service avec le même bar j'ai un peu
perdu deux points j'ai pris beaucoup de
tricheries hier 200 bagues ou triche
assimilés du coup j'ai perdu pas mal de
points je n'en peu repris ce matin
encore et en live
il va être en train d'arriver à dire est
une minute un pareil juste à la fin
arrive au bon moment
on va pouvoir quitte katia gagner mais
honnêtement c'était c'est un match
absolument inintéressant au blad mais on
va on va mettre le bon set-up lenval
batteur on va mieux de voir dans
quelques secondes
yo yo yo je vais te tu veux tu équipé
d'un casque pas tu as le temps le temps
on n'a pas vraiment commencé lettres
commencent à s'équiper yoyo salut tout
le monde salue la francophonie mme je
suis pas mal aux oreilles ça va ça va tu
es sûr dans le truc qui tape sur ton
travail là bas c'est toujours comme ça
ça va ça va alors c'est quoi le secours
ces 14,7 savoir d'os x tout plus de
poids n'a pas énormément recevoir va
ouais mais après c'était c'était pas
trop quoi dire c'était un match elle est
tellement plus forte quatre heures en
fait c'était prévisible
emplissez apporte au tournant ya pas
photos réf c'est que je vois dans cette
partie de sa pas l'air très bien c'était
un peu ça dans toutes les parties mais
sauf que en fait le match a tourné qu'à
mener 3 1 ouais et l'autre avaient tour
de plus nana avait tour de plus et
activités 1 minute 30
et là elle a réfléchi une minute pour
essayer de trouver le gain est là pas
trouvés de maths et elle a fini par
perdre tout réactivité mais c'était
genre enfin j'ai pas ça se finisse et
sans réfléchir et le match toros
terminer comment alors c'est demain les
deux matches aujourd'hui y avoir un seul
y avait un seul avec mes à demain ça va
être
il va c'est quoi c'est willy fans contre
bibi sahara et le deuxième je sais plus
c'est vrai pourquoi t'es risque d'être
intéressant r ouais et on sait très bien
pourquoi ce pour des raisons multiples
pour des raisons multiples c'est juste
de taper ville du sahara sur google non
vous a été tout viré je sais pas j'ai
pas de ça encore sir encore tous les
tous les tricks sur google while the
watch et intrigant intrigant intrigant
très intrigant même voilé ensuite parce
qu'on en a marre allez on revient dans
une seconde gens voient leur aide ou pas
je sais même pas si je peux envoyer le
raid bon jeu